>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
WE ARE STARTING TO LEARN SOME OF
THE LARGE BUT STILL UNKNOWN
NUMBERS OF AMERICANS IN THE LOW
HUNDREDS.
WHO WERE OFFENDED BY THAT U.S.
MILITARY TO SPEAK AND REMAIN
TRAPPED IN THE TALIBAN
-CONTROLLED AFGHANISTAN.
THE SACRAMENTO BEE HAS REPORTED
AT LEAST 2,000 STUDENTS ENROLLED
IN THE SAN JUAN UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
ARE STRANDED SOMEWHERE IN
AFGHANISTAN TONIGHT.
NO ONE IS CERTAIN WHERE THEY ARE
OR HOW THEY ARE GOING TO GET
HOME.
THE WHITE HOUSE HAS NOT
COMMENTED.
WHAT IS SO INTERESTING THAT THE
CONTRACT THAT INFORMS AS IS OVER
THE PAST WEEK GET THIS THING
ADMINISTRATION HAS OVERSEEN THE
EVACUATION OF TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF UNVENTED AFGHAN NATIONALS.
MANY OF WHOM WILL NOW BE MOVED
TO THE NEIGHBORHOOD AROUND THE
UNITED STATES.
THEY DID NOT SEEM TO ENCOUNTER
ANY PROBLEMS IN DOING THIS.
UPPER THANKS TO METICULOUS AND
THOUGHTFUL PLANNING OPERATION
CHANGE AMERICA FOREVER CAME OFF
PRECISELY ACCORDING TO PLAN.
IT WORKED FLAWLESSLY.
BUT A COUPLE OF DOZEN AMERICAN
SCHOOLKIDS TRAPPED IN
AFGHANISTAN, THE WHITE HOUSE IS
NOT REALLY INTERESTED IN WHAT
HAPPENS TO THEM.
SO THE PAST THAT PURPLE YIELD TO
TONY BLINKEN, WHICH SHOWS YOU
HOW COMPLETELY UNIMPORTANT TAKE
CONSIDER IT.
IF THERE'S LEFT IN AFGHANISTAN,
WE ARE GOING TO STAY UNTIL WE
GET THEM ALL OUT.
RIGHT.
HE DID NOT MEAN THAT.
SO WHAT IS TONY BLINKEN'S PLAN
TO GET THEM ALL OUT, TO RESCUE
THE AMERICAN CITIZEN'S TRUCK
TONIGHT IN AFGHANISTAN?
AS BLINKEN TOLD US THE RESIDENTS
OF HAITI AND THE REPUBLICAN --
REPUBLIC OF CONGO HAVE SAID,
SAID, BE WHERE WE MEET UP IF YOU
WOULD NOT WANT TO SEE THE
REPUBLIC OF CONGO WHEN IT IS
METROPARK THAT IS THE KIND OF
WEEK IT HAS BEEN PURPLE BUT
WHENEVER YOU THINK WE HAVE
REACHED PEAK INSANITY, THEY
DOUBLED DOWN.
THIS AFTERNOON, SUPPOSEDLY
PRESIDENT OF THEY ARE STATES
APPEARED OUT OF NOWHERE AND
DECIDED TO SPEAK IN PUBLIC --
PUBLIC.
DID YOU SEE IT?
WEIRD IS JUST THE BEGINNING.
SO FIRST OFF, FOR EXAMPLE, BIDEN
NS THAT THE UNITED STATES IS
DONE WITH AFGHANISTAN FOREVER.
WE ARE GONE AND WE ARE NOT GOING
BACK EVER.
THEN BIDEN ANNOUNCED THAT WE
"HUNT DOWN SOMETHING CALLED
ISIS-K WHICH SOUNDS LIKE A NEW
LINE OF COSMETICS FROM KIM
KARDASHIAN.
ISIS-K, BIDEN SAID, MAYBE HIDING
IN AFGHANISTAN.
IN WHICH CASE, WE WILL HUNT THEM
DOWN THERE, IN AFGHANISTAN.
WE ARE NOT WOOLITE LEADING
AFGHANISTAN.
WE COULD BE BACK RECENT.
THE WHOLE SPEECH WAS LIKE THAT.
IT WAS DISORIENTING.
AND AT ONE POINT, BIDEN BRAGGED
ABOUT, HISTORICALLY SUCCESSFUL
MILITARY AND INTELLIGENCE
OPERATIONS WE HAVE JUST
WITNESSED, ALL OF US TOGETHER.
APPARENTLY BIDEN IS UNDER THE
IMPRESSION THAT THE ENTIRETY OF
UNITED STATES HAS LEFT
ELECTRICAL POWER AND NO ONE HAS
A WORKING INTERNET CONNECTION.
THIS IS WHAT HE SAID.
>> President Biden: WE
COMPLETED ONE OF THE BIGGEST
AIRLIFT IN HISTORY BUT MORE THAN
120,000 PEOPLE EVACUATED TO THE
SAFETY.
OF NUMBER IS MORE THAN DOUBLE
WHAT MOST EXPERTS FELT WERE
POSSIBLE.
NO NATION, KNOW NATION HAS EVER
DONE ANYTHING LIKE IT IN ALL OF
HISTORY.
THE ONLY -- BELIEVE UNITED
STATES HAD THE CAPACITY AND THE
WILL AND THE ABILITY TO DO IT
AND WE DID IT TODAY.
THE EXTRINSIC SUCCESS OF THIS
MISSION WAS DUE TO INCREDIBLE
SKILL AND BRAVERY, AND SELFLESS
COURAGE OF THE NEXT IT'S
MILITARY AND OUR DIPLOMATS AND
INTELLIGENCE PROFESSIONALS.
>> Tucker: SO NO NATION IN
HISTORY HAS EVER DONE ANYTHING
LIKE THIS.
POSSIBLE.
HE DID NOT MEAN IT LIKE THAT THE
KEY IS TELLING US THIS WAS THE
BERLIN AIRLIFT, PLUS D-DAY, PLUS
THE INVENTION OF YOGA PANTS.
THIS WAS A TRIUMPH OF AMERICAN
BRILLIANCE AND INGENUITY AND
WILL.
50 YEARS FROM NOW, YOUR
GRANDCHILDREN WILL CELEBRATE
FALL OF KABUL DAY WITH TEARS OF
PRIDE IN THEIR EYES.
MY ANCESTORS DID THAT, TABLE
THING.
AS WE SAID, IT WAS DEMENTED.
IT WAS LITERALLY DEMENTED.
BUT OVER AND THE WHITE HOUSE,
THEY SEEM TO BELIEVE EVERY WORD
OF IT.
THE EARTH LOSING CONSCIOUSNESS
FROM HAVING THEIR OWN FUMES.
WHAT BIDEN CONTINUE.
>> President Biden: THE BOTTOM
ONE, 90% OF AMERICANS IN
AFGHANISTAN, ONE LEAVE WERE ABLE
TO LEAVE.
>> Tucker: BIDEN WENT ON TO
REPEAT WHAT TONY BLINKEN TOLD US
YESTERDAY, WHICH IS TO BEND WILL
PROBABLY ALLOW THOSE REMAINING
10% OF AMERICANS THAT LEAVE AT
SOME POINT POSSIBLY.
HE EVEN EXPLAINED WHY THE
CHILDREN WOULD ALLOW THIS OR
WHAT WE SHOULD BE CERTAIN IF
THEY WILL ALLOW IT TO OPPOSITE.
IN THE SINK SPEECH THAT HE
PRAISED THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY OFFICE EXTERNALLY
SUCCESS JOE BIDEN, ADMITTED THAT
YES, THE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE
COMPLETELY MISSED THE FACT THAT
AFGHANISTAN PURPOSE GOVERNMENT
WOULD FALL APART IN A WEEKEND.
>> President Biden: THAT
ASSUMPTION THAT THE AFGHAN
GOVERNMENT WOULD BE ABLE TO HOLD
ON FOR A PERIOD OF TIME BEYOND
MILITARY DRAWDOWN TURNED OUT NOT
TO BE ACCURATE.
>> Tucker: TURNED OUT NOT TO
BE ACCURATE.
THE PRESIDENT OF AFGHANISTAN,
WHO IS A COLLEGE PROFESSOR
HANDPICKED BY THE COLLEGE
PROFESSORS WHO RUN OUR
GOVERNMENT GET THE CONSPIRACY OF
MORE ON SPREADING THE GROWTH.
THAT GUY LEAD THE COUNTRY IN AN
HOUR WITHOUT TELLING ANYBODY
INCLUDING HIS PEDDLERS CIA.
HE HAD NO IDEA.
BUT THAT WAS AN EXTRAORDINARY
SUCCESS, ET CETERA JOE BIDEN.
NOTHING COULD HAVE BEEN DONE TO
AVOID THE DISASTER THAT YOU HAVE
WATCHED, TO AVOID THE IMAGES YOU
ARE SEEING ON THE BLUE SCREEN
RIGHT NOW.
I WOULD BE THE TALIBAN DRESSED
UP AS THE AMERICAN SOLDIERS
CHECKING OUT THE HELICOPTERS WE
LEFT FOR THEM.
WE HAVE NO CHOICE BUT TO LEAVE,
$90 BILLION OF SOPHISTICATED
MILITARY EQUIPMENT TO THE
TALIBAN.
WE ARMED THE TALIBAN, 20 YEARS
AFTER WE ARRIVED IN AFGHANISTAN
TO BEAT THE TALIBAN BACK TO THE
STONE AGE, THEY ARE NOT ONE OF
THE BEST ARMED MILITARIES IN THE
WORLD.
AND THAT WAS A GREAT SUCCESS.
WHY DIDN'T THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION FIGURE OUT HOW TO
TAKE THIS EQUIPMENT WITH US OR
AT LEAST DESTROY IT?
NO ONE HAS ANSWERED THAT
QUESTION.
BUT THE KEY THING IS, THEY ARE
NOT ASHAMED BY IT.
AT ALL.
EFFECTIVE NOW THEY ARE TELLING
US THEY WANTED TO GIVE THE
TALIBAN MORE AID DIRECT CASH
PAYMENT.
IT IS NOT THAT WE ARE MAKING
THIS UP.
YEAH, BECAUSE IT IS REAL.
WATCH THE INITIAL SECURITY
ADVISOR TO THE STOTHERT JAKE
SULLIVAN -- STOTHERT JAKE
SULLIVAN EXPLAIN A PERFECT WHEN
IT COMES TO OUR RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE TELL BEEN TO THAT WILL
BE THE TALIBAN'S ACTIONS.
FOR AMERICANS -- THEIR
COMMITMENT TO NOT ALLOW
AFGHANISTAN TO BE A BASE FROM
WHICH TERRORISTS CAN PROTECT THE
UNITED STATES OR ANY OTHER
COUNTRY.
THEIR COMMITMENTS WITH RESPECT
TO UPHOLDING INTERNATIONAL
OBLIGATIONS.
IT IS GOING TO BE UP TO THEM AND
WE WILL WAIT AND SEE BY THEIR
ACTIONS HOW WE END UP RESPONDING
IN TERMS OF THE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT ASSISTANCE.
>> Tucker: YOU GOT TO THINK
TALIBAN ARE SITTING ABOUT THEIR
TEAPOT EASING UP AND THINKING,
THAT KID IS THE INITIAL SECURITY
ADVISOR FOR THE GREAT STATE?
MAYBE IT IS NOT SO GREAT.
YOU THINK THEY'VE TAKE JAKE
SULLIVAN SERIOUSLY QUICK TO
THOSE OF US POINTED DENIED
STATES WOULD NOT CONSIDER TAKING
JAKE SULLIVAN SERIOUSLY FOR A
SECOND.
UP YOU CANNOT COUNT ON THAT KID
TO GET YOUR STARBUCKS ORDER
RIGHT.
AND HE IS THREATENING THE
TALIBAN, WE ARE GOING TO GIVE
YOU MORE AID?
THEY ARE ONE OF THE WEAKEST AIR
FORCES IN THE REGION.
SO THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
NOT GOING TO ADMIT ANYTHING.
AND THE KEY THING THEY ARE NOT
GOING TO ADMIT IS THAT WE JUST
LEFT A WHOLE LOT OF AMERICAN
CITIZENS INCLUDING
SCHOOLCHILDREN IN A COUNTRY WE
TURNED OVER TO BARBARIANS WITH A
HISTORY OF KILLING AMERICANS.
NO ONE IS GOING TO ADMIT THAT.
INSTEAD, THE GENIUSES, THE
RHODES SCHOLARS ARE GOING TO
TREAT THE TALIBAN LIKE THE REST
OF OUR ALLIES, WHICH MEANS
PAYING THEM A LOT OF
IMPLEMENTING AND TELLING YOU
THAT THEY ARE DOING WHAT WE TELL
THEM TO DO WHEN THEY ARE NOT.
SO WHAT WE ARE WITNESSING IS A
TOTAL LACK OF TOTAL AND PROFOUND
AND OBVIOUS LACK OF
ACCOUNTABILITY FROM THE PART OF
THE PEOPLE MAKING DECISIONS THAT
AFFECT THEIR LIFE AND THAT HAVE
ENTERED THE LIVES OF MANY
AMERICANS.
THIS BOTHERS PEOPLE.
IT DOES NOT MATTER WHO YOU VOTED
FOR IN THE LAST ELECTION, THAT
IS NOT AN ACCEPTABLE SYSTEM.
AND THE PEOPLE PART OF THE MOST
ARE THE ONES WHO JUST LOST THEIR
SONS IN KABUL.
MARK SMITH HAD A SUN NAMED JARED
WHO WAS KILLED IN THE KABUL
BOMBING.
HERE'S WHAT HE SAID.
"I'M NOT TRYING TO INSULT THE
PRESIDENT.
BUT IT JUST NOT NOTHING THAT
APPROPRIATE TO SPEND THAT MUCH
TIME ON HIS OWN SON WHEN YOU'RE
THE ONE RESPONSIBLE FOR
ULTIMATELY THE WAY THINGS WENT
DOWN.
YOU KIND OF YOU LIKE THAT PERSON
SHOULD OPEN IT A LITTLE MORE.
"YEAH.
YOU THINK?
LECTURING US ABOUT HIS OWN SON?
WITH ALL RESPECT?
WHEN YOU STOP TALKING ABOUT
YOURSELF FOR A MINUTE, YOU
APOLOGIZE FOR THE PEOPLE WHOSE
SONS YOU GOT KILLED.
WE SPOKE WITH ONE OF THE FATHERS
WHOSE SONS WAS KILLED.
ED GREENE'S MOTHER JUST POSES --
POSTED A MESSAGE.
"YOU TURNED TO WALK AWAY AND I
LET YOU KNOW MY SON PURPOSE BUT
WAS ON YOUR HAND."
OKAY.
SHE IS THE GRIEVING MOTHER.
FACEBOOK IN RESPONSE CENSORED
HER.
INSTAGRAM, WHICH FACEBOOK OWNS
DELETED HER ACCOUNT ENTIRELY.
AND THAT IS WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
YOU CONTRADICT THAT HEAD OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THAT ELDERLY MAN WAGGING HIS
FINGER IN YOUR PIECE IN THAT
WHICH IS TELLING YOU HOW TO
RAISE IMPLICATED.
WHAT WE JUST SAW IN AFGHANISTAN
IS THE MILITARY TRUMP.
YOU MUST AGREE OR WE WILL MAKE
YOU -- TRIUMPH.
YOU DISAGREE.
WATCH.
>> HE NEEDS TO DO HIS JOB
COMPETENTLY AND WELL.
HE HAS PROVED.
HE HAS DONE WITH NOBODY THOUGHT
POSSIBLE SO FAR ON COVID.
OBVIOUSLY, HE IS FACED WITH THE
DELTA PERIOD AND TRYING TO MAKE
THAT BETTER.
EXCEPT AFGHANISTAN THINK WENT
WAY BETTER THAN MOST PEOPLE
EXPECTED TWO WEEKS AGO.
>> Tucker: WHAT IS FUNNY IS
THAT DR. WHO HAS GOT A TRACK
RECORD OF DECADE-LONG IS ONE OF
THE GENIUSES WHO GOT US IN
AFGHANISTAN IN THE FIRST PLACE
IN THE DIED -- LIGHT TO THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC ABOUT THE.
HE HAS NEVER APOLOGIZE FOR THAT.
HE SAID HE DOUBLE DOUG COLMAN
ANYONE WHO DISAGREED WITH
ANYTHING HE OR ANY OF THE
POLITICIANS HE HAS WORKED FOR,
HE HAS CALLED THEM UNPATRIOTIC.
WHAT MAKES US ALL EVEN MORE
NAUSEATING IS THAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION APPEARS TO THE
DEGREE.
THEY ARE NOT EVEN SELF-AWARE
ENOUGH TO KNOW HOW BADLY THEY
HAVE FIELD.
THEY HAVE NO CAPACITY FOR SELF
GROUP -- SELF REFLECTION.
HE TWEETED EMPTY COLUMN FROM
JENNIFER RUBIN ABOUT WHAT A
GREAT JOB THEY ARE DOING.
HERE'S THE HEADLINE.
THEY DESERVE MORE CREDIT FOR
THEIR EFFORTS TO EFFECTUATE
AMERICANS FROM AFGHANISTAN.
[CHUCKLES]
THE COLUMN CONTINUES THAT YOU'RE
SKEPTICAL ARE AMERICANS TRAPPED
IN AFGHANISTAN.
YES, THEY WERE ABANDONED BY THE
U.S. MILITARY, WHICH EXIST TO
PROTECT THEM, BUT IT DID NOT FOR
SOME REASON.
"IT IS POSSIBLE THAT SOME OF THE
250 MIGHT NOT MAKE IT OUT.
COULD SOME AMERICANS FACE
PHYSICAL ABUSE "?
APPELLEE.
OTHER THINGS WE GOT WRONG?
ON THE FLIPSIDE, GENERAL BEEN
SAYS, ," THE HERCULEAN EFFORT TO
EXTRACT THOUSANDS OF AMERICANS
AS THE TALIBAN SEIZE CONTROL OF
THE COUNTRY SHOULD NOT GO
UNNOTICED OR UNAPPRECIATED.
NOTICE THE DOUBLE NEGATIVE.
THE HALLMARK OF THE MORNING.
BUT IT IS NOT JUST TUMBLED JEN
RUBIN THINK IT IS WITH THE STATE
DEPARTMENT BELIEVES.
THOSE ARE THE PEOPLE WITH THE
PENTAGON NOW TELLS US WERE IN
CHARGE OF RESCUING POSTSCHOOL
KIDS FROM AFGHANISTAN.
AMERICANS WONDERED HOW TO GET
HOME BECAUSE THEY HAVE BEEN
DEBATED, THESE PEOPLE ARE
CONGRATULATING THEMSELVES.
PUBLIC DEBT SHOULD NOT SURPRISE
US BECAUSE IT IS EXACTLY WHAT
THE PENTAGON HAS BEEN DOING FOR
DECADES.
THIS IS THE SECRETARY OF DEFENSE
IN 2011.
EXPECT ONCE YOU HAVE
ACCOMPLISHED IS EXTREMELY
BECAUSE OVER THE LAST
YEAR, ESSENTIALLY, YOU HAVE
INJECTED THE PADDLE -- CALIBAN
FROM THE.
METALIK -- TERRITORY.
AND IF WE CAN HOLD THIS
TERRITORY AND EXPAND THE BUBBLE
THAT I THINK BY THE END OF THE
YEAR THAT WE CAN TURN THE CORNER
IN THIS CONFLICT.
>> Tucker: THE -- THE END OF
THE YEAR WOULD HAVE BEEN EXACTLY
TEN YEARS AGO.
WE DON'T MEAN TO SINGLE OUT
DR. HEIGHT WHO IS PROBABLY ONE
OF THE SMARTER PEOPLE TO OVERSEE
THIS DISASTER, ONLY TO POINT OUT
OF THIS DISASTER DID NOT START
TEN DAYS AGO.
IT STARTED IN OCTOBER OF 2001 OF
THE TALIBAN WAS EJECTED.
OF IF YOU'RE GETTING A SENSE
THAT THE SAME PEOPLE WHO HAVE
BEEN READING THE SAME SCRIPT FOO
SOMETHING AND THEN THEY ARE
STILL DOING IT RIGHT NOW.
TODAY, PRETENDING EVERYTHING IS
A FUN.
WATCH AS THE PENTAGON THE
SPOKESPERSON SAID, YES,
AMERICANS ARE TRAPPED IN KABUL.
BUT THAT IS NOW DIFFERENT FROM
WHAT AMERICANS TOURISTS IN THE
CARIBBEAN WHO LOSE THEIR
PASSPORTS PERSPECTIVE IT IS NOT
UNLIKE WHAT WE DO ELSEWHERE IN
THE WORLD.
WE HAVE TO AMERICANS THAT GET
STRANDED INTO COUNTRIES ALL THE
TIME.
AND WE DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
TRY TO FACILITATE SAFE PASSAGE.
>> Tucker: SO LET'S SAY YOU
ARE OR AREN'T A WATERS PPI AND
YOU LOSE YOUR PASSPORT.
IT IS KIND OF LIKE THAT.
THE TALIBAN TAKE OVER.
SO YOU GET CREATURES LIKE THE
ONE YOU JUST SAW WHEN
INSTITUTIONS ARE NOT HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR BAD
DECISIONS.
THEY CAN SIT WITH EVERYTHING
WANT NOW MATTER HOW RIDICULOUS,
NO MATTER HOW ABSURD AND THEY
KNOW THERE WILL BE NOW
REPERCUSSIONS.
BUT JOE BIDEN HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PUNISH THE PEOPLE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THESE FAILURES
FOR MORE THAN 20 YEARS AND HE
SAID HE CALLED THE WHOLE THING
AN EXTRAORDINARY SUCCESS.
HE SAID AFTER HE -- REPORTERS
SHOUTED QUESTIONS AND FOR A
MOMENT, IT APPEARED POSSIBLE TO
BUT WOULDN'T MIGHT INTERACT
IMPLICATED BACK AND WALKED
TOWARD THE PODIUM.
THAT HE REALIZED HE JUST